undocumented immigrant whose arrests
pushed an Illinois town into the center
of the national immigration debate has
been freed from a detention center
juan carlos hernandez Pacheco was
released yesterday on three thousand
dollars bond immigration agents took him
into custody last month his detention
led to an outcry from residents and
elected officials in West Frankfort and
many of them are supporters of President
Trump President won the county was more
than 70 percent of the vote Anna Warner
is in West Frankfort and she spoke with
Hernandez just hours after his released
in an interview that you'll see only
here on CBS this morning and a good
morning a good morning you know about
8,000 people live here in West Frankfort
and judging by the response to this many
of them know this man juan carlos
hernandez Pacheco they say he's an
important member of the community the
question is will he be allowed to stay
the community of West Frankfort raised
money to bring their friend home in
style to his family after nearly three
weeks in detention how are you doing
he's an undocumented immigrant they
claim as one of their own juan carlos
hernandez Pacheco first of all I think I
need to be grateful because why for all
the support his friends Tim Grigsby and
Mark Williams
we've known Carlos for over ten years
he's one in a million I think you know
if you were gonna model someone off of
you know whether it be your your own
children or yourself
I mean he's that type of person
Hernandez has lived in Southern Illinois
for nearly 20 years on February 9th
immigration officers arrested him at his
home they were looking for someone else
but found he was here illegally did you
ask him why for my previous record in a
statement ice pointed to Hernandez his
two convictions for DUI in 2007 he's now
sober but under the previous
administration experts say those
misdemeanor offenses likely would not
have gotten him picked up
and people here alcohol many of whom
came to greet him last night at the
restaurant he managed wrote letters of
support the mayor police officials and
people he's helped with fundraisers and
donations this is a person that I would
that I would put right there on that
pedestal everyone should be looking at
him going you know what I need to be
more like Carlos under Trump
administration directives
experts say he's also now the type of
person who may be deported when mr.
Trump talked about deporting more people
who did you think he was going to deport
well I mean obviously you know it was
murderers rapists and you know people
like that well that's obviously not
carlos hernandez himself says he doesn't
blame the president he's protecting the
country I got three kids and a wife
they're American citizens I do believe
is doing the right thing he's protecting
my family he's protecting your family
even despite what just happened to you
you think that but that has nothing to
do with him I don't believe that I don't
believe the heat focus on me I'm not a
target I don't feel that way
for now as we said he is out on bond
while his application for legal status
works its way through the immigration
system his lawyer told us that he's
hoping that Carlos has a good chance
because his wife is a US citizen as are
his kids of course Anthony very nice to
see the community support for Amana
thank you